hi I'm Erik Bosse and this is a
breakdown of the Walking Dead Season
nine episode 14 titled scars referring
to the scars on Michonne and Daryl's
scars whose origins are finally revealed
this episode boy isn't that but shown
had to slice through a bunch of creepy
children of the corn like Anna Cain in
the Jedi Temple Michelle what wait to do
ah I'm gonna break down everything you
might have missed but before I begin
thank you to Philo for sponsoring this
video stay tuned for a little later in
this video to learn how you can start
watching episodes of The Walking Dead
within seconds and it's a special offer
the first 50 people to sign up using our
link will get their first month a Philo
for free ok this episode opens with
Michonne before the time jump as we hear
this music this is boy geniuses souvenir
and Michonne discovers this souvenir in
the mud Rick's Colt Python revolver the
shown is still pregnant with RJ here
she's still wearing her headband because
she hasn't read on her dreads yet and
you get further tell this is all
flashback footage because it's D
saturated in general the coloring on The
Walking Dead is pretty be saturated
already like if you were to reduce
everything to solely the colors on
screen this is a show about grey things
and brown places which I always
interpreted as a nod to Robert Kirkman's
black and white comics but further
desaturating this imagery is how the
show connotes an earlier time period you
may remember this season 6 premiere used
a similar effect for flashbacks there's
another visual detail confirming we're
seeing in the past Daryl's vest he is
both angel wings here when as we saw in
the present time period one of those
wings was worn off and I want to point
out this exchange between Michonne and
Daryl you okay being alone
you not there's an interesting double
meaning with the Sean's words it seems
like Michonne is saying that she's not
alone
she has Rick's child RJ and Judith of
course but we could also read this says
Michonne saying she's not okay that
despite having Rick's kids she still
feels lonely and Rick's absence is still
weighing on her her character art for
this episode is to let go of Rick and
embrace the next generation of kids the
flashback scenes revealed a major event
that led to alexandria's isolationism
the arrival of Jocelyn's group joseline
is an old friend of Michonne's from
college and she leads a group of
orphaned children when they rescue these
kids from their hideout they pass these
instructional signs for how to hunt and
skinned deer and rabbits right away we
learned that these kids are expert
hunters and trappers and I guess mosey
errs in retrospect Jocelyn's initial
approach Alexandria with Mitchell and
Winnie was probably a recon a way for
her to scout this target before bringing
in the rest of her child army the
relationship at the heart of this
episode is between was shown and Judith
with Judith Nagi and her mother and her
uncle Daryl her stories about the past
Freddie stories how everyone fought the
Savior's in ways they can do that again
Meighan actually echoes Judith's
curiosity about legends later they're
old and when we next see the past event
that Judith is supposedly curious about
it's taking place during Halloween time
they're wearing costumes there's ghost
decorations of pumpkins for one this
imply that Jocelyn's group was playing a
long game they were in Alexandria for a
while gradually building up trust but it
also suggests that this is kind of a
ghost story itself a haunting cautionary
tale meant to scare Judith and scare the
Alexandrians into distrust of the
outside and yeah this ghost story is
definitely one of the darkest moments
we've seen on the series I pointed out
before how this season seems to be
embracing horror cinema tropes like
Connie's silent run through the
cornstalks de vocht a quiet place or
signs in beta last episode was modeled
on Michael Myers from Halloween this
episode is going fooled children of the
corn
it's a Stephen King story about a cult
of children and corn who murder adults
these kids aren't as creepy but that
soulless laugher Mitchell sure was
uh-uh-uh-uh-uh
I will take the kids now mature who
passes this manhole leading down to the
sewers beneath Alexandria which is now
sealed shut
it's a callback to the route that Carl
used how he led Alexandria to safety
when needed bombed the town from Joan
this former connection to the outside
world is now a vulnerability it
represents how her past open-heartedness
bitter in the ass Michonne and Daryl
tracked down Jocelyn's group to this
school and there's an interesting detail
here that you might have missed but
first thanks again to Philo who
sponsored this video along with our
recurring coverage of these final
episodes of The Walking Dead Season 9 I
now use streaming services to get all of
my continent cut the cord folks silo is
perfect for me it has over 50 channels
including AMC and Comedy Central it's
really the easiest way to watch The
Walking Dead I can start watching
walking dead within seconds there's
unlimited recording so I can save as
many shows as I want Philo is available
on Apple TV Roku Android iOS Fire TV
it's simple in affordable only $20 a
month for all of this content
I'm saving 100 bucks a month on my cable
bill it's really been the best solution
to stay cord free and commitment free
and a special offer to you guys the
first 50 new rock stars fans to sign up
using our link will get their first
month of Philo for free just visit WWF
Aiello TV slash new rock stars
that's pH Aiello TV slash new rock stars
ok back to the school you may recognize
this filming location this is where the
cannibals from terminus led by Gareth
ate Bob's leg in season 5 Dane had Nate
this school is once again a setting
where a captive turns the tables on the
cap door now the fact that joseline has
gathered around a dozen kids implied
that she killed or manipulated these
kids into killing dozens of parents
earlier in the episode joseline actually
hinted to Michonne exactly what happened
none of the adults in our group made it
they just the children they grow they
learn capable of anything
and now we see exactly what joseline
meant by breaking she gets these kids to
torture Michonne and Daryl with these
hot cattle style brands they may wonder
why they're doing this if they're just
Glenny to kill them anyway later the kid
lioness mentions a possible explanation
Martok you kill our mark hmm mark our
kill kill our mark suggests it could be
another hunting thing but that doesn't
really make sense considering that was
winnie who mark Michonne not - I think
for Jocelyn this goes way deeper the
branding isn't just about delivering
pain to the victim it's a symbolic
ritual for the children to desensitize
them from empathy and thrive control it
control you
Michonne and Daryl escape leading to
this very very dark sequence in which
Michonne has to slash her way through
these brainwashed kids to save Judith
the killing children is awful to watch
but it it's worth noting that this level
of violence has been part of the walking
dead since the beginning in the opening
scene of the series the first Walker we
see Rick put down is that of a little
girl and seasons later Carol escalated
the violence by killing Lizzie none of
us will ever look at the flowers the
same way again but in this episode the
directing effectively justifies it the
most shocking visual for me was the shot
of lioness slashing at Michonne's womb
and this little goes back four seconds
later it becomes impossible for us to
see these kids as innocence because
there are even more vulnerable innocence
that they are hell-bent on killing also
the editing is a good job avoiding
showing us the actual mutilation of
these kids by inner cutting with
present-day shots Michonne with Walker's
last surviving kid is Winnie who runs
off perhaps she'll show up again later
maybe as a teenager maybe with the
whispers or some other group and when
Judith appears in the door notice for a
second was shown isn't sure if she's a
walker a doubt that Michonne confirms
later this is a callback to the famous
Sofia moment season 2 the moment Carol
broke upon realising the worst fate come
to her missing daughter
now Daryl doesn't participate in this
slaughter but he doesn't make his
feelings pretty clear earlier on some
people just got so much evil in their
heart this image he evokes of wearing
masks sheds light on Daryl's present-day
hatred of the whispers who of course
wear masks and are also a group who
freely dragged their children into
violence back in the present day
Michonne learns that Judith actually
remembered this ghost story but that
Judith made it out of this uncorrupted
well sort of descripted by the right
mama notice your
it's the same downward stab that we saw
Michonne news on Jocelyn and by the way
that last Walker who grabs Judith
apparently that's talking dead host
Chris Hardwick
after visiting Carl's grave in
Alexandria we returned to this idea of
scars the title this episode it's mostly
reference to Daryl and Michonne but the
word itself actually comes from
different characters kids worried about
their future Henry talks about his
stitched up wound it's gross and it's
gonna leave a huge scar
and thank you to Lydia for only weirdly
fingering it instead of licking it like
Lydia does to Carl's car in the comics
and at the end of the episode
Judith brings up scars again no it's
okay if it does the mother and daughter
learned that scars aren't just evidence
of a time that you were wounded it's
also a sign of healing and living with
scars shows far more strength than an
ability to scar others ever could but
here's my question for you guys which
violence against children moment was
darker for you
Michonne killing Jocelyn's kids or Carol
killing Lizzie common down below with
your thoughts follow me on twitter and
instagram @ e a boss and subscribe to
new rock stars on youtube is arrived to
our podcast where we get your podcasts
thanks for watching bye
[Music]